[slow electronic music]
♪ ♪
In the modern world,
technology is inescapable.
People spend all day
at their computers.
Life today is just
one big video game.
The pixels on their screens
make them feel joy, sadness,
other emotions
I can't think of right now.
- Whoa, Matt.
Whoa, you almost ran into me.
- Oh, sorry.
I was just thinking about--
- "Society Tomorrow"?
God, it really gets
in your head, doesn't it?
- Yeah. I just got to
the episode last night
where the GuardWrist
makes Barbara kill herself.
- Fuck!
- [groans]
- It sounds like there was
a momentary lapse in judgment,
and a mistake was made.
So I think all we need
is an apology.
- I'm sorry I spoiled
an episode for you.
- [sighs]
I accept your apology.
- That's nice.
- No!
Not in my mouth!
- I actually took
some initiative
and investigated
the cause of the layoffs,
and I think I found a way
to save thousands of jobs.
- Wow. Jake...
how did you have time
to do this
and also watch
"Society Tomorrow"?
- Oh, yeah, I--
I didn't watch it.
[tense music]
- Jake, I specifically
instructed you
to watch "Society Tomorrow."
- I know.
I just thought this was
more important.
- Forget everything
you think is important.
♪ ♪
There is a storm coming,
and when it comes,
none of us will be safe,
least of all you.
♪ ♪
That's a line
from episode three.
[laughs]
Dude, you got to watch.
But also,
there are going to be layoffs,
so that line does kind of
apply to you. Hmm.
- And she was like, "No! No!
Not in my mouth!
Blah!
♪ ♪
Oops.
And then there was just, like,
blood and guts,
like, everywhere.
- Grace, I need to file
a formal complaint.
- No! Not in my mouth!
No.
- I'm sorry, Jake.
The cinematography
was just so... cinematic.
- I thought
I could trust you!
- The GuardWrist
is listening to us.
It knows that
we're plotting against it!
- No, please.
You don't have to do this.
- I have to get
this thing off of me!
Because corporations!
- No!
- [screaming]
[tense music plays on devices]
[device beeps]
♪ ♪
- Glen,
what happened to you?
- If you're gonna
keep watching this show,
I am not giving you
a ride to work tomorrow.
And I was planning
on stopping for doughnuts!
And I am not Glen!